are you set up your life well there's an
app for that there is a new app called
stranger and it lets you live through
the light
I love a stranger is that confusing
let's look at a video
cool
on
gun
guy we got a little info there but now
we've got the facts for you
the app tracks your path pulling related
photos from Foursquare Google Maps along
the way
neither person if the actively do
anything I think this is the interesting
part
and no locations are ever specifically
named so anonymity is preserved at the
end of the experiment each person has
one chance to send a message to the
other either to say goodbye
or to exchange contact information so
just to be clear about what's going on
here
this is stop it all being pulled from
your phone for 20 days so you're not
actively posting to a
it's just basically watching everything
you're doing for 20 days
party meetings this is called hardly
think this is crazy you know we went
from like
you know when Facebook started you
actually were friends with the people
that you were friends with
then you suddenly became friends with
people that we're friends with your
friends
now you're friends with people you don't
know and now you your friends are people
going to give a fuck about
so this is just the next natural step in
whatever this whole
bone is doing dollar I can't think of a
more useless
application that they are you came you
live anonymously as someone else do you
know it's like all those people do
past-life regression turns out they're
all kings
it is that same thing you know your you
never think the other person connected
to was a fucking dock worker in Russia
you know anything at all this there's a
guy who's unload a truck in eastern
poland
let's book and see what he's doing all
day he's drinking unloading shit and
then going to bed
woohoo right now that you agree but we
have such short attention spans what are
the chances anyone could follow through
with twenty days are being somebody else
people yeah it was the the Jewish boy
that was literally the worst commercial
ever seen
they were held at different times that
work that drop it
yes yeah ok rate that's really all that
was walking
also look for it's all of it where you
at it's quiet there
is the right now okay I'm in a car I
don't know it's quiet
be was an elevator probably be
background musics about whoever's car is
God's will
I don't know I gotta figure this thing
out but so much but we could in this
break down walls between nations you
could see how
the israelis get the other palestinians
are living the russians could see how
the ukrainians really think it but they
could just turn on the TV or go on the
internet or read something
this is bullshit this is on believe this
is a failure I'll
I give me something here this is gonna
go is is gonna be just as unpopular the
hula hoop
a.m. I'll stick April and I did really
well here
I think that the the the beauty in it
would be in the specificity and their
bragging about the lack especially
like and got bar yet what want to take
naked pictures of the budget black all
your face right now I'll be out for that
city with the person but
a1 other person for 20 days you're
supposed to
you don't have anything going on in your
life I don't have enough time to get to
this
people are already but no to return the
emails they gonna be track and someone
you don't even know was probably boring
that's why they signed up for this thing
yeah I think interesting people do this
the %uh this'll fail and then that all
the six weeks into its failure they'll
be like that we put a dick pic component
today
yeah or it gets bought for three billion
bucks in there yes but there's nothing
with those those
there's a grinder and tender and all
that shit i mean that that that's gonna
are you kidding me added I you're very
optimistic I
israeli and a palestinian area to be
like I don't be both girl who are ready
to get the paper I K
yeah what while I'm at a security
checkpoint they're playing Tetris a
tractor
well I thought maybe there was something
here but maybe
maybe this is because I'm a little
younger than you getting that were
happening here well look you were making
SodaStream bottles and then get healthy
with rubber bullets
a alright it's not going to create I
cried okay killed it